south africa's president suro ramaphosa
has had to reprimand the country's
finance minister today for
comments he made about zambia after
zambia's president edgar lungo fired the
central bank governor denis
titon bolweny of south africa tweeted
that presidents in africa
must stop this nonsense of waking up in
the morning and
fire a central bank governor you cannot
do that this is not some fiefdoms of
yours
your personal property no nam boheni
further went on to say that
that governor was a good fellow why do
we do these things as africans
the president of zambia must give us the
reasons why he dismissed the governor
or else hell is on its way i will
mobilize
mr boweny has since deleted his tweets
but he did say that
he stood by his statement adding that
the central bank independence
was not negotiable to talk more on this
we've invited dr situm bego musa
returned onto the program he served as
the finance minister of zambia
between 2008 and 2011. he is a member of
the opposition
united party for national development
welcome to dw news africa doctor
so south africa's finance minister is
insinuating
that this is an issue of central bank
independence
do you know what he's talking about is
the independence of
zambia's central bank under threat
yes uh um by the way i also saved as a
deputy governor of the central bank of
zambia so i understand exactly what he's
talking about
yes i think it's correct to feel that
the central bank independence is being
threatened first of
all because of the manner by which the
governor has been uh fired
person that we all felt was doing a good
job
fired without any explanation um
obviously that shows that uh there is no
independence
but we also believe that uh some of the
statements that the governor may have
been
uh issuing in the last few days uh
causing the government about the needs
to scale down on borrowing
and that may have annoyed the government
but even the minister of finance has
been saying the same thing he's been
stating the same things
that there's need for government to
control borrowing
because it's getting out of control the
the leader of your party
mr hakayinde who challenged president
edgar lungu
he wrote in a column that the sacking of
the central bank governor
he quoted another sad development for
zambia
what is happening in zambia
it is another sad development because
everyone knows that
zambia is going through severe economic
problems
uh not just because of the coverage 19
like everywhere else but because
of the extraordinary amount of debt
indebtedness that zambia is in
and at this time one would have expected
that uh to tackle these
serious economic problems good
experience hands
would have been required like that of
the sacred governor
to steer around this problem and this is
a man that
was there even during the uh epic uh
days when zambia and many african
countries were heavily indebted it was
part of the team that got zambia out of
that
uh less so he's an experienced man to
deal with the issue that we are
confronting today and to take him out
this time obviously it's a sad day for
zambia
okay i mean this is this is the behavior
of of a president who who
who who knows he can rule with impunity
almost to say
um and just to i guess support that we
know that human rights groups have said
that
democratic freedoms have have been
eroded in zambia under president edgar
lungu
um is this a classic case of power has
corrupted the man
absolutely uh just to give you a
specific example
we are going preparing for elections for
next year
and part of that process in con
in compliance with the constitution says
that the
political parties themselves going to
elections must go through
must go through political elections
but when our party goes for these
conventions for intra-partulations
we get arrested okay but when the ruling
party is
doing the same thing they are allowed so
how do you
even start elect arresting parties
doing inter party elections in
conformity with the constitution that
says that you cannot go into an election
unless there's a democratic process
within your own budget
but to try and do that get arrested
this is just an example of the
democratic space that is shrinking every
day
in our country all right that is dr
situm
he's talking to us from the countryside
in zambia
thank you so much for the time you've
given us sir